نظام ابتكره رئيس امريكي اسبق وعدل عليه
عالم الرياضيات واصبح الحل سحري
للانتخابات في العديد من دول العالم
لتوزيع مقاعد البرلمان على الاحزاب
المتنافسه بطريقه فعاله انه نظام هوند
النظام المستخدم حاليا في الانتخابات
التركيه بعد انتهاء التصويت وفرز الاصوات
يتم احتساب نتائج القسم المتتاليه لكل حزب
على حده الحزب الذي يحصل على ناتج قسمه
اكبر يفوز بمقاد واحد وتعاد عمليات القسمه
من جديد حتى يتم توزيع جميع المقاعد هذه
الطريقه تضمن ملء جميع الشوارع الا انها
تمنح افضليه حسابيه بعض الشيء للاحزاب
الحاصله على عدد اصوات اكبر عرف النظام
باسم جفرسن نسبه للرئيس الامريكي توماس
لكن عالم الرياضيات البلجيكي فيكتور دهون
طوره لاحقا عام
1878 ومن هنا صار النظام يعرف باسمه